Що відбувається з цінами на житло в Україні через можливий напад Росії?
Напруга на російсько-українському кордоні змусила людей дещо притримати свої гроші
і не купувати нині квартири так активно,
як вони робили це майже весь 2021 рік, стверджують експерти.
Інвестиційний банкір Сергій Фурса вважає, що соціальна напруга є вагомим фактором
у прийнятті рішення щодо купівлі квартир.
Чи може ця історія з навколишнім галасом, з потенційною загрозою Путіна
зупинити зростання цін? Теоретично може. Тому що деяка частина покупців
може відкласти прийняття рішення, допоки ситуація не стабілізується.
За кілька місяців можна буде більш детально аналізувати, як новини
про можливу війну вплинули на ринок нерухомості, вважає економіст.
Однак є дані, які вже зараз свідчать, що зміни на ринку відбуваються.
Денис Суділковський разом з командою щомісяця аналізують ціни на квартири
у великих містах Україні. 2021 рік був рекордним у зростанні вартості квадратного метра.
З весни 2021 року ми бачимо вперше за останні 7 років суттєве
здорожчання первинного житла. Так можна сказати, що на поточний день,
якщо вимірювати від лютого до лютого, у Києві ціна за квадратний метр виросла
з тисячі доларів до 1290 доларів. У Львові ціни підросли на 17%,
в Одесі на 13%. Рекордсменом з росту цін стало київське передмістя
у межах п’яти кілометрів навколо адміністративних кордонів Києва
вартість житла виросла аж на 34%.
Проте в останні два місяці таке стрімке подорожчання квартир припинилося.
За даними аналітиків, влітку квадратний метр дорожчав в середньому
на 50 доларів щомісяця. А от грудень 2021-ого, січень 2022-ого
показали середнє зростання лише на 10 доларів.
Частково тому, що впав попит на житло.
Експертка з ринку нерухомості Вікторія Нікітенко вказує на те, що хоч соціальна напруга
впливає на рішення купити житло, є й інші причини.
По-перше, українці традиційно менше думають про житло у грудні та січні,
бо заклопотані святкуваннями й відпочинком. По-друге, окрім російської загрози,
люди також вичікують, яка буде ситуація з цінами на газ, на будівельні матеріали,
загалом з інфляцією. Таке затишшя одразу відчувають забудовники.
Так от, показники основних, ключових девелоперів столиці і девелоперів з регіонів,
я маю на увазі Львів, Одеса, говорять, що за цей період середнє падіння попиту
у таких от системних, стабільних гравців сягало десь 30-35%.
Були прецеденти 40-45%, навіть 50%, це, як правило, стосувалося житла масмаркету.
Як можуть скористатися падінням попиту ті інвестори, які все ж хочуть придбати квартиру зараз?
Вікторія Нікітенко радить придивитися до дисконтів, адже саме в зимові місяці
знижки на житло найвищі.
Що залишається робити (забудовникам)? Або демпінгувати ціною -
звичний формат для деяких гравців, або викатувати супердисконти.
Ці дисконти були вищі середнього по ринку. Якщо в середньому
ми говоримо в межах 8-10-12% в період затишшя, ось цієї сезонної сплячки.
То, якщо ви спостерігали за ринком і за деякими гравцями,
ви могли бачити 15-16% на певні квартири.
За словами експертки, зазвичай такі знижки ставлять на квартири
з нестандартним плануванням чи на нижніх поверхах.
Однак саме цього сезону великі дисконти були на звичайні домівки на середніх поверхах.
Ще один варіант, який може зараз привабити покупців житла -
це вторинний ринок. За словами Вікторії Нікітенко, власники
вторинного житла зазвичай категорично відмовляються робити знижки на свої квартири.
Однак цього року ситуація змінилася.
І ось тільки цей період такої психологічної напруги цього року -
"вторинка" продемонструвала дисконти. Особливо це стосувалося Харкова,
і всіх тих регіонів, які були під пресингом найбільше.
Чернігів це також було містом, де просіли ціни. А трохи виросли
ціни на "вторинці" у Львові. Очікувано.
Найвищий дисконт, який можна було знайти на "вторинці" - це 15%, каже Нікітенко.
Тож  двокімнатна квартира у Харкові, яка коштувала орієнтовно 73 000 доларів,
могла вам обійтися в січні у 62 000 доларів.
То чи зараз хороший момент для тих, хто не боїться нападу Росії,
щоб інвестувати у житло? На думку Сергія Фурси, все залежить від того,
наскільки серйозно оцінюють загрози з боку Росії покупці та продавці.
Простір для спекуляцій завжди є. Питання в тому, що є дійсно певна частина
власників нерухомості, яка налякана, то ці люди можуть розглядати
якомога швидший спосіб продати свою нерухомість, як спосіб врятувати свої гроші.
На це може зреагувати частина покупців, які мають гроші, які не розглядають
варіанти російського вторгнення, і в такому разі, вони могли би купити те, що подешевшало.
Всі експерти погодилися, що паніка в інформаційному просторі
не стала настільки потужною, щоб похитнути ринок житла.
Однак деякі зміни вона все ж внесла. Тому українці, які скептично ставляться
до новин про можливий напад Росії, саме можуть цими змінами скористатися.
Все ж таки, я думаю, минуло значно менше часу з рокрутки цієї ситуації,
ніж потрібно, щоб люди реально запанікували і категорично відмовилися від купівлі.
Я думаю, паніка була, і вона ще лишається, але вона має точковий характер
і впливає на дуже вразливих людей. А дійсно інвестори й покупці,
які налаштовані на придбання житла з інвесторською метою або для себе,
вони навіть не розглядають всерйоз цей фактор, а більш сконцентровані
на оцінці ризиків того, що відбувається в соціумі.
Та допоки зростає інфляція, а державна програма іпотеки не доступна
більшості громадян, купівля власного житла залишиться мрією,
а не реальним планом, для чималої кількості українців.